depuis trois jours voilà à quoi se
résume une étape d'un circuit organisé
au cimetière américain de colleville
descendent de buts devant les grilles
bien clauses beaucoup de frustration et
une petite photo souvenir en guise de
compensation pourtant pour certains
tour-opérateurs la visite reste encore
indispensable
on continue quand même à passer devant
le cimetière parce que c'est vrai que
c'est incontournable de toute façon les
gens le demandent et au cas où ça aurait
rouvert on ne sait jamais je viens quand
même devant le cimetière pour voir un
peu ce qui se passe des noms peu de
nouvelles redire face à la fermeture du
site le guide a donc dû s'adapter côté
pratique trouver des lieux d'aisance
alternatif pour soulager ces messieurs
dames et côté programme parler du
cimetière sans pouvoir y rentrer on va
prendre ce chemin marchait le long de la
plage et après on va suivre un petit
sentier aménagé mais quelques marches ne
l'est pas tant que ça pour satisfaire
ses clients stéphane cros à son astuce
faire le tour par le sentier de la plage
20 minutes de chemin de croix pour enfin
apercevoir le mémorial sur la pointe des
pieds
you can not vous ne pouvez pas entrer
dans le site mais là c'est
ça convient c'est suffisant
c'est mieux que rien
ce n'est pas suffisant malheureusement
ça peut pas les satisfaire totalement
dans le sens ne sont pas dans le
cimetière mais sans les flancs une
grosse part des frustrations savait déjà
ils m'ont vu voilà ça leur a fait en
effet
même de l'autre côté du mur et le chant
du souvenir conserve sa puissance
d'évocation les touristes du jour j
devront s'en contenter d'ici le vote du
budget américain